Joe Biden has had an unfortunate GAF that
some are saying is representative of his underlying
racism. Others are saying it's representative
of just as underlying ignorance. And even
others are saying it's representative of his
underlying sort of slowness and confusion
that a, some believe he's experiencing cognitively.
Biden said poor kids are just as smart as
white kids. Check it out. We have this notion
that somehow if you're poor, you cannot do
it for kids are just as bright and just as
town's white kids, [inaudible]
wealthy kids, black kids, Asian kids not really
mean, but think how we think about it.
So the interpretation is that he meant to
say poor kids are just as smart as wealthy
kids, but instead he said white kids both
start with a w and then he sort of smoothed
it out by listing a few types of kids and
made it seem like it was his plan all along.
Poor kids. It's just are just as smart as
white kids, wealthy kids, Asian kids, Latino
kids, et cetera. And there are two sides here
and I think ultimately that's actually an
irrelevant debate. Was this like this a gap?
It was a gap and that it sounded really bad.
Is there anything here that confirms some
kind of inherent racism by Joe Biden? Not
inherently, but again, it does not sound good.
There are lots of people in this country who
do straight up believe that white kids are
smarter than poor kids and poor kids.
They mostly see as being non white. Like that's
not a completely uncommon belief in this country.
We know that that exists. The overwhelming
majority of those voters aren't voting in
the Democratic primary anyway. So that actually
seems like a bit of a departure from the key
issue here is this evidence that Joe Biden
is inherently racist. It's not evidenced by
itself. It is evidence that Biden is some
combination of sort of tired and maybe out
of touch in terms of how we discuss some of
these issues today, but then the re there's
really a more serious issue here that even
if poor kids and wealthy kids in the United
States have the same potential at birth and
some kind of genetic basis, there are countless
studies that show that poverty does negatively
affect academic outcomes and ultimately life
outcomes. The real important issue here is
that poverty hurts the potential of kids after
they are born.
Hunger hurts the potential of kids to do well
in school. Absent parents hurt the potential
of kids. Lack of access to educational resources
hurt a child's potential. That's a real takeaway.
That's a real issue and the same people on
the right who are just saying, oh, look at
racist Biden. Okay, Biden may have antiquated
beliefs on race. He may be racist. He may
have just misspoken, could be some combination
of these things, but all of those people who
are just saying, look at racist Biden, they
don't want to deal with the destructive effect
of poverty on educational and career outcomes.
Poverty really hurts your ability to do well
in school and ultimately in life if you want
to take this seriously rather than focusing,
you know, the Biden Gaffe element, which is
not new. Biden is hugely gaffe prone and that's
not anything we, we've avoided talking about
on this program.
Let's focus on dealing with poverty, which
are elected officials and primarily those
on the republican side are completely unwilling
to do Republicans and Democrats the same on
many issues perpetuating the status quo that,
uh, continues to have the same types of people
put in elected office. We've talked about
all of the ways that Republicans and Democrats
are too similar, but we've also talked about
many of the ways that Republicans and Democrats
are very different. Republicans and Democrats,
very different. And who as presidents, they
appoint to the Supreme Court and the lower
courts, very, very different Republicans and
Democrats, very different. On Net neutrality,
we talked about that last week in the context
of Elizabeth Warren's new net neutrality and
maybe as importantly public internet proposal
and Democrats and Republicans, very different
in terms of what should the country be willing
to do. And by the country, I mean people with
our tax money in terms of how that tax money
is allocated to deal with poverty, to deal
with hunger.
And in order to really do that, we have to
understand the destructive effect that poverty
has on kids in their ability to do well in
life. And you can pick celebrities or athletes
who were dealt a bad hand and did really well.
They are statistically irrelevant. I don't
mean I don't care about them, but I mean statistically
that is not even really an important part
of the mobility conversation that we need
to be having. And that's really the issue
that we should be talking about here. But
GAF, no question about it. Evidence that Biden
is inherently racist, certainly not by itself,
but very, very much hitting on an important
issue that even though poor kids and wealthy
kids may have the same potential, at least
in some hypothetical sense, the reality of
poverty is absolutely crushing.